رائد ابو سيده الذي عاد من اوكرانيا اهلا
بك رائد نبدا بمؤشرنا اليه استهداف
المحطات الطاقه المكثف من قبل روسيا كيف
يقاوم المواطن الاوكرانيه يوميا قسوه
الشتاء مع انعدام الكهرباء واحيانا المياه
في بعض الاماكن والتدفئه بطبيعه الحال
محطات الطاقه وخصوصا على محطات الكهرباء
بدات منذ 10 من اكتوبر ولكن هناك تركيز
همم تركيز على ذلك لجعل حياه المواطن
الاوكراني صعبه جدا وخصوصا في همم فصل
الشتاء مثلا مدينه مدينه كيف هناك تقنين
للكهرباء بحيث تعمل الكهرباء في بعض احياء
ويتم قطعها ساعتين او اكثر عن الاحيان
الاخرى ان ذهبنا الى المدن الجنوبيه
وخصوصا اكثر المدن المتطوره هي مدينه
اوديسا بحيث تم استهدافها اكثر من مره اخر
مره كانت قبل همم قبل يومين في عطله اسبوع
المدينه تغرق بالظلام بشكل كامل ويقوم
مواطن بشراء المولدات الكهربائيه التي تم
وضعها في في باب كل محل تجاري عند السيف
في شوارع اوديسا ممكن عد اكثر من 100 مولد
كهرباء امام كل باب فتغير صوت المدينه
التي هي مدينه على البحر الاسود تغير
صوتها الى اصوات المولدات الكهربائيه طنين
هذا المولدات التي تسمع في الشارع وانقطعت
الكهرباء انقطعت شبكه المياه لانها
مواتير ضخ المياه الى ودوسها تعمل على
الكهرباء بدون كهرباء فهي لا تعمل هناك
مدينه بلا كهرباء في منطقه الوضع مختلف
لان القطاع الكهربائي يعود الى تسعه اشهر
يعني عندما كانت القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه الموجوده على في شاق همم
ميكو لايف في منطقه هناك همم مرحله الاولى
هناك تدميا مستودعات كهربائيه قام الجيش
الروسي التي استخدمها كقاعده عسكريه
بتدميرها وهناك ايضا تدمير لخطوط الكهرباء
الاسلاك والكابلات تم تدريعها تد من قبل
معك ما يتم اليوم في ميكولايب هو تحدثنا
الى مدير شركه الكهرباء هناك قال ان
الكهرباء تعمل ساعتين وتقطع اربع ساعات
ليتسنى توزيعها ولكن 80 قريه في محيط بلده
سنيغريف كم مقطوعه عن الكهرباء بشكل من 90
الى 100% اكثر من تسعه شهور ذهبنا الى
مدينه خيرسون مدينه خيرسون مقطوعه من
الكهرباء بعد انسحب الجيش الروسي منها تم
اعاده الشبكه قالت لنا وليست البلديه هناك
ان هم عادوا الشبكه الى 60% ولكن القصف
الروسي اعادها الى مستوى ضعيف جدا وهنا
قاموا بوضع ما تسمى بخيمات الصمود هي ثلاث
خيمات بحيث يتم في هذه الخيمه نقاط
للكهرباء التقينا مع طلاب جامعه ياتون
للدراسه في هذه الخيمه مع اشخاص ياتون
للدفئ لان هناك هي خيمات مدفاه يمكنما
الحصول على مشروبات ساخنه والحديث مع
بعضهم البعض بهذا الرغم من ذلك فهي خلقت
هذه الخيمات نوع من التعاضد والتضامن
الاجتماعي بين السكان طيب رائد هناك عندما
تتحدث عن المناطق المحرره اليوم هناك
بدانا نتحدث عن اعاده الاعمار كرنك مؤتمر
دولي امس في باريس ولكنك ايضا موضوع ازاله
المحاولات الروسيه لتغيير ملامح الشخصيه
او الهويه الاوكرانيه في المدينه كيف لمحت
ذلك في مدينه خيرسون لانها تعد خرسون بحسب
القانون الروسي منذ الاستفتاء مدينه روسيه
فتم تغيير هناك تغيير كان على اكثر من نوع
حل المرحله التعليميه اي خلق مدارس فقط
بمناهج روسيه وحاولوا قالت لنا احنا
المعلمات انهم حاولوا استقطاب معلمين هذه
الصور التي
كان هناك لائحه كتب عليها روسيا يقوم هذا
للعمال الاندرويد
بازاله العلم الروسي ووضع هذه الصوره كتب
عليها ايها المواطنون انتم احرار ووضعت
بالعالم الاوكراني والعالم الروسي
اتفقنا هذه الصوره هي
لجمعيه تسمى شو اسمه وهي تبحث عن
المتعاونين مما سمتهم الخونه وهو جزء اخر
لذلك هناك اكثر من مستوى لمحو ازال از او
ازاله الاثار الروسيه الاول التعليمي
باعاده المدارس وسحب جميع الكتب الروسيه
التي كانت تدرس الثقافه وكان وفي هذه
الكتب تحدثنا الى حد الجنود من القوات
الخاصه اغاني الكتب وضعوا فيها ما يسمى
بيت تجربه جزيره القمر
التي كانت اوكرانيه وعادت الى روسيا انها
التجربه ناجحه هذا فيما يتخلص بما يتعلق
بالمستوى والتعليم ولكن هناك المستوى
الاقتصادي هناك مجموعه من الابل والمواد
الروسيه الموجوده لذلك يتم سحب حروب من
المحلات التجاريه ويتم بيع باسعار زهيده
ورخيصه جدا المنتجات الروسيه للتخلص منها
هناك ايضا ما يسمى
كانت تتحدث عن المتعاونين او متساويين الخ
هم يبحثون عن كل من تعاون مع اللبوس وكل
من
تعاون مع الجيش الروسي
ولو بنسبه قليله هل هناك ما زال متعاطفا
مع روسيا بعد هذه الحرب تغيرت العقليه
تماما ومن كان ربما بين البلدين اصبح
موقفه التغير
ثقافيه يعني اللغه الروسيه هي جزء من
ثقافه خيرسون الناس يرفضون الحديث اليوم
بلغه هي كانت لغته من الام يرفضون الحديث
باللغه الروسيهم فقط يركزون على الحديث
باللغه الاوكرانيه هذا نوع من ايضا ولكن
ايضا هناك من النوع همم الثقافيه التي
تتعامل معه جسمه هو ايضا الباحث عن كل
اولئك الذين ارادوا ان تكون خرسانه روسيه
وتعامل مع ذلك فهميه عن هؤلاء المتعاونين
الذين يتم عقابهم بشكل كامل قال لنا لا
رحمه لا رحمه اهم هذا ما قالته رئيسه
البلديه هذا ما قاله الجنود لنا حتى هذه
الصوره عندما نتحدث مع اندريه يعني كعامل
يقول لنا نحن نريد ان نغير صوره المدينه
صوره شوارع المدينه هذه اوكرانيا وستبقى
خلصون اوكرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك رائد ابو سيده